[Musique]
bonjour à tous très heureux de vous
retrouver pour un nouveau numéro de
Parlement Hebdo l'émission qui revient
sur l'actualité de la semaine au
Parlement avec vos quartiers guilders
oui Alexandre et nous accueillons cette
semaine Daniel Simonet bonjour bonjour
vous êtes député la France insoumise de
Paris merci d'être avec nous pour revoir
le riche film de la semaine et on
viendra sur les propositions de loi du
groupe la France insoumise à l'assemblée
qui ont commencé à être examinés en
commission par les députés des textes
qui portent sur de nombreux sujets à
l'IVG la corrida ou encore
l'implantation du beurre en France le
projet de loi d'orientation et de
programmation du ministère de
l'Intérieur qui poursuit son chemin à
l'Assemblée nationale il augmente les
moyens des forces de l'ordre sur tout le
quinquennat mais vivement critiqué sur
les bancs de la gauche
et puis au Sénat trois textes
budgétaires au programme cette semaine
budget de l'État budget de la Sécurité
sociale et rallonge budgétaire face à la
hausse des prix
et c'était un peu la semaine de votre
groupe Daniel Simonet puisque
l'assemblée examinait les propositions
de loi de LFI au titre de la journée
réservée de l'ordre du jour à la France
insoumise examen tous azimut en
commission on fait le résumé de ces
multiplex avec Elsa mandingava on en
parle après
plus de 10 textes discutés en commission
et un seul succès pour les insoumis seul
leur proposition de loi
constitutionnelles garantissant l'accès
à l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
et à la contraception a été adoptée elle
était défendue par la présidente du
groupe la France sonnerait à introduire
ses droits dans la Constitution elle
s'illustrerait alors comme une nation
pionnière en la matière pas le même
succès pourrait Caron qui entendait
interdire la corrida vous cherchez
toutes les excuses que vous pouvez chers
collègues tradition culture économie
biodiversité et vous cherchez ces
excuses pour vous cacher
pour vous cacher il y a une seule
question qui vous est posée aujourd'hui
est-ce que vous êtes favorable oui ou
non à la torture animale la majorité des
députés Renaissance sont contre le texte
du député insoumis pour notre part nous
ne voulons pas interdire normé et
réguler nous sommes fiers de cette
France qui vit dans chacun de ces
territoires alors qu'en 1968 l'extrême
gauche se battait pour le slogan il est
interdit d'interdire en 2022 il ne se
passe pas une semaine sans que la
nupaisse ne cherche à proposer une
nouvelle interdiction pas non plus de
Smic à 1600 euros ni d'allocation
d'autonomie pour les jeunes ou encore de
réintégration des soignants non vaccinés
Clémentine Autain n'a de son côté pas
réussi à imposer sa proposition de loi
contre la concentration des médias quant
à vous Daniel Simonet les députés ont
rejeté votre demande de commission
d'enquête sur le rôle joué par Emmanuel
Macron dans l'implantation du beurre en
France
Daniel Simonet vous présenter au titre
de votre groupe une douzaine de 12
exactement propositions loi inscrite à
l'ordre du jour en commission 11 d'entre
elles ont été examinées avec une seule
adoptée celle de Mathilde panot la
présidente de votre groupe on dit qu'en
séance publique le 24 novembre elle
pourrait être là encore adoptée et voter
notamment par les députés de la majorité
est-ce que ce serait si c'est le cas un
symbole fort pour vous oui inscrire dans
la Constitution le droit à l'avortement
et le droit à la contraception ce serait
un message extrêmement fort parce qu'on
est dans un contexte vous allez vu les
régressions dans nombre de pays sur le
droit à l'avortement notamment aux
États-Unis et donc si la France inscrit
dans sa constitution elle sera pionnière
ce sera le premier pays à le faire parce
qu'il faut se rendre compte que les
menaces de remise en cause du droit à la
consacre contraception
sont imminent dans plein d'endroits de
par le monde y compris en France rien
n'est acquis pour toujours mais la
majorité à déposer elle aussi un texte
porté par Aurore berger la présidente du
groupe Renaissance le vôtre est passé
avant en examen à l'Assemblée nationale
vous avez bonne espoir qu'il soit adopté
que la majorité donc Renaissance vote un
texte de la France insoumise oui pour
l'instant on était dans l'étape des
commissions donc nous avons voté le
texte de hors berger et notre texte a
été aussi adopté en commission il sera
présenté en premier la différence entre
les deux textes c'est que le nôtre
inscrit le droit à l'avortement et le
droit à la contraception dans la
Constitution par contre nous nous
interpellons néanmoins le gouvernement
pour que le droit à la droit à l'IVG et
à la contraception soit bien inscrit
dans la Constitution sans passer par un
référendum il faudrait que le
gouvernement prenne l'initiative d'un
projet de loi et à ce moment-là vous
avez la réunion du Congrès sans qu'on y
a passé soit qu'on est voilà mais
puisque ces deux textes obtiennent la
sentiment d'une majorité de
parlementaires et bien on estime que le
gouvernement on va prendre ses
responsabilités vous demandez un projet
de loi du gouvernement car on le
rappelle c'est une proposition de loi
constitutionnelle donc pour qu'elle soit
adoptée il faut aussi que le Sénat
l'adopte dans les mêmes termes or la
majorité de droite du Sénat est contre
elle trouve que c'est un texte
symbolique qui n'a aucune efficacité
juridique qu'est-ce que vous leur
répondez alors d'abord c'est important
d'inscrire des droits fondamentaux dans
la Constitution parce que cela permet
d'éviter que au gré des majorités
parlementaires un tel droit si important
qui permet aux femmes de disposer de
leur corps leur liberté et bien ne soit
remise en cause au détour d'un texte de
loi et puis aussi inscrire ce droit
cette liberté c'est aussi inscrire la
notion gratuite d'accès à l'IVG et à la
contraception donc
le gouvernement si il met en place il
fait adopter une un projet de loi à ce
moment-là nous n'avons plus besoin aussi
d'avoir recours au référendum parce que
si on a recours un référendum vous allez
voir tous les groupes puisque d'extrême
droite anti IVG pollué et créer une
ambiance extrêmement
néfaste pour le débat de notions nos
droits fondamentaux alors on va parler
de la proposition de loi que vous avez
déposée qui n'a pas été adopté en tout
cas en commission pour créer une
commission d'enquête sur les
hubert-falls qui pointent du doigt le
rôle du président de d'Emmanuel Macron
quand il était ministre de l'Économie
précisons le de François Hollande
qu'attendez-vous de cette commission
d'enquête qu'elle fasse la lumière sur
la complaisance éventuelle d'Emmanuel
Macron alors ministre avec le lobby uber
ou alors vous attendez qu'elle dénonce
un modèle celui du Berre en France qui
serait éventuellement contraire avec
l'intérêt républicain supérieur mais les
deux en fait la première la première
question qui nous est posée en tant que
parlementaire c'est comment est-ce que
ça peut être possible qu'une plateforme
américaine puisse venir s'implanter en
France en piétinant en bafouant les lois
de la République en organisant de la
contrefaçon taxi
maraude électronique était illégal à
travers
uberpop en respectant pas le code du
travail et en faisant un lobbying de
dingue pour pouvoir faire en sorte
d'imposer l'état de fait à l'état droit
c'est des pratiques déjà pour vous ça ah
oui ça a été des pratiques extrêmement
problématiques et ensuite il y a dans ce
contexte des de la de l'activité très
agressive du Berre dans son lobbying il
y a qu'elle a été l'attitude en fait à
la fois du ministre de l'économie de
l'époque et de différents publics
puisque les uber-files donc les travaux
des journalistes révèlent qu'il y a eu
au moins 17 rencontres non inscrites à
l'agenda entre le ministre de l'économie
de l'époque Emmanuel Macron et des aux
dirigeants du Berre et notamment Travis
calanic mais deuxième aspect l'enquête
parlementaire doit aussi se préoccuper
mais les conséquences de l'ubérisation
d'un point de vue social écologique
économique environnementale on en fait
quoi mais rapidement sur ce sujet les
députés en commission qui ont rejeté
cette proposition de création de
commission d'enquête on dit qu'on ne
pouvait pas enquêter sur l'action passée
du président de la République actuelle
qu'est-ce que vous leur répondez alors
j'ai sentiments que les macronistes
visiblement sont tellement attachés la
défense du de leur monarque
présidentielle qu'ils en arrivent à
déformer ce qui se décrit dans notre
Constitution il y a à prendre notre
Constitution pour encore plus
monarchique qu'elle ne l'est déjà à
partir du moment où l'enquête
parlementaire est une enquête
parlementaire on n'est pas dans une
enquête judiciaire d'ailleurs le
consortium de journalistes estime à la
fois qu'il y a des zones d'ombre
problématiques du point de vue du Berre
mais que les 17 rendez-vous du ministre
de l'économie non inscrit à l'agenda
n'était pas entre guillemets illégal il
pose question sur le fonctionnement
démocratique éthique mais on n'est pas
dans l'ordre judiciaire parce que lui
exactement ce défend en disant que
c'était dans le cadre mais ça n'est pas
pour autant que ça n'est pas moi
problématique et donc l'objet de
l'enquête ça doit être aussi de voir
quels sont les recommandations possibles
à mettre en place pour faire en sorte de
mieux organiser la séparation des lobbys
de l'État et de faire en sorte que
l'intérêt général la collective sur
l'intérêt général en République c'est
quand même la base et bien ne dépendent
pas de ces pressions de lobby et qu'on
puisse se protéger là-dessus et on voit
que la loi Sapin 2 est insuffisante donc
les recommandations là-dessus sont
nécessaires et ensuite le rôle des
députés et bien de contrôler la façon
dont les gouvernements gouvernent donc
on est à partir du moment où on est sur
une enquête parlementaire d'abord sur
les sur le lobby Dube et ensuite sur les
décideurs publics dont un ministre
fut-il aujourd'hui président de la
République on a le droit d'enquêter
allez on va passer à une proposition
d'une autre commission d'enquête autour
de l'affaire Hanouna Boyard on le
rappelle le député de la France
insoumise a été insulté par l'animateur
dans son émission sur C8 alors que Louis
Boyard venait critiquer Vincent Bolloré
le propriétaire de la chaîne cette
commission d'enquête elle souhaite
porter sur la concentration des médias
dans les mains de quelques industriels
pourquoi pour poser une commission
d'enquête qui avait déjà été réalisée
l'an dernier par le Sénat avec un
travail identique alors non ce que l'on
ce que l'on demande déjà
d'abord la scène est complètement
hallucinante la scène est hallucinante
vous avez un député de la République qui
interrogé sur la question de
l'immigration insiste aussi sur les
causes et montre bah oui regardez les la
responsabilité des milliardaires dans
l'exploitation l'exploitation des
richesses le pillage et les catastrophes
écologiques et donc il cite le cas de
Bolloré sauf que on est sur la chaîne
dont Bolloré et le patron le premier
actionnaire et donc vous avez le
présentateur qui empêche finalement le
député de pouvoir s'exprimer
démocratiquement sur la question de
Bolloré et qu'il est poursuivi par
camerounais et on ne peut pas lui
permettre d'aborder cela et finalement
le monsieur Hanouna explique que il est
là justement pour défendre son patron
donc on va bien que la concentration des
médias qui fait que vous avez 9
milliardaires qui possèdent 80% des
médias pose une vraie question
la France insoumise doit-elle boycotter
les émissions notamment TPMP
le problème c'est que si vous décidez de
boycotter une émission ça veut dire que
vous considérez que tous les autres
journalistes de tous les autres
émissions ne posent aucun problème alors
c'est sûr que là je trouve que Hanouna a
mis la barre très haut quand même dans
l'insulte dans le dans dans les respects
et puis dans dans dans le côté censure
bon mais le boycott est rarement une
solution parce que sinon si vous décidez
de parler de boycotter toutes les
chaînes qui sont tenues par des
milliardaires bah à ce moment-là on va
où on a sur votre chaîne et je vous en
remercie de l'invitation mais voyez bien
que d'un point de vue démocratique c'est
un piège problématique maintenant Louis
bien les gars a raison de porter plainte
pour outrage voilà à personne quand même
dépositaire de l'autorité publique quand
on est député il demande que le débat
sur la chaîne Hanouna sur justement
l'affaire Bolloré puisse avoir lieu et
par ailleurs quand nous avons nous saisi
l'arcom la ministre Isabelle borne a
aussi saisi la recom pour envoie d'une
procédure de sanctions donc les choses
sont en cours alors outre à faire à la
faire 4 nains avec le député de la
France insoumise qui pourrait faire son
retour à l'Assemblée nationale on
rappelle qu'il avait reconnu des
violences conjugales et ce qu'il est le
bienvenu dans votre groupe ou est-ce
qu'il doit démissionner mais c'est clair
que pour nous il ne doit pas
démissionner maintenant la question et
c'est ce nom nous discutons dans le
groupe c'est quelles sont les conditions
de son de son retour qui à la fois lui
permettre de poursuivre
c'est comment dire son divorce qui va
forcément on en doute pas être médiatisé
un moment donné et préserver aussi du
coup le le la parole la parole du groupe
et la poursuite de notre engagement
évidemment contre les violences exophane
de fait aucun doute pour qui que ce soit
et je pense qu'on a de cette histoire
tout ça bien réfléchir et à chaque fois
que nous le pouvons transmettre ce
message comme dans un couple il y a des
tensions des difficultés au point que la
communication
dysfonctionne de manière systémique
ayant toujours conscience que on peut
éviter et on doit tout faire pour éviter
le passage à la violence on doit tout
faire notamment avoir recours à une
thérapie conjugale il faut à chaque fois
faire passer le message que tous les
couples peuvent éviter tomber la dent
par contre
systémique qui fait que ben voilà les
violences faites aux femmes ce sont des
violences à chaque fois
ce sera la discussion du groupe voilà
alors il y a une autre affaire Sonia
Chikirou qui est qui risque d'être mis
en examen député de la République
c'était dans le cadre de le financement
de la campagne de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
votre réaction ça vous surprend c'est la
suite logique
des choses qui ont été entamées par
rapport à cette campagne on sait que les
choses les choses les choses se
poursuivent hein à ce sujet là moi je
rappellerai que la campagne
présidentielle de Jean-Luc Mélenchon si
vous prenez les les exactement si vous
prenez les quatre cinq candidats à
l'élection présidentielle c'est la
campagne qui a coûté la moins chère
c'est la campagne qui a coûté le moins
cher donc
les comment dire l'enquête va poursuivre
son cours voilà moi j'ai pas besoin de
je n'ai pas à commenter chacune des
étapes les mises en examen ne sont pas
encore effectives et ne présage pas du
tout de de la culpabilité ou pas mais je
rappelle une chose on a fait la campagne
électorale la moins chère voilà et par
contre dans le dossier Macron de sa
campagne présidentielle pourquoi est-ce
qu'elle ne fait pas l'objet d'une étude
alors que pour le coup non seulement la
coûter très cher mais on sait
pertinemment qu'il y a eu des des dons
de la part de de grands patrons qui
étaient au contraire pourquoi est-ce que
ça ne suit pas son cours à ce niveau-là
on va passer au deuxième thème de cette
émission la loi Love Me de son nom de
code loi d'orientation de programmation
du ministère de l'Intérieur qui prévoit
15 milliards d'euros supplémentaires
pour la police et la gendarmerie en
défendant son texte Gérard Darmanin
s'est targué d'avoir le soutien des
sénateurs écoutés le Sénat a suivi le
gouvernement alors qu'on sait que
naturellement le Sénat ne suis pas
forcément le gouvernement dans une quasi
unanimité politique
s'inspirant je crois de la position que
nous avons toutes et tous pour la
sécurité de nos concitoyens adoptant des
abonnements de tous les bancs
nous avons à 27 voix près fait voter un
texte qui prévoit 15 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires sur cinq ans et qui je
crois est très attendu par l'ensemble de
nos concitoyens et par les agents du
ministère de l'Intérieur
alors Gérard Darmanin se félicite
d'avoir beaucoup de soutien des
sénateurs des sénateurs et aussi des
députés de LR et aussi de beaucoup de
députés mais pas forcément des bancs de
gauche vous vous n'êtes pas d'accord
avec beaucoup de dispositions notamment
l'aggravation des peines encourues en
cas d'outrage sexiste elle est fit à
voter contre pourquoi mais en fait le
problème c'est que c'est pas en
augmentant à chaque fois les amendes
qu'on arrive à résoudre le problème vous
savez c'est un texte de droite donc
c'est logique qui soit soutenu par la
droite il y a notamment un aspect
totalement scandaleux dans ce texte
c'est le recours aux amandes
forfaitaires délictuels ça ça m'inquiète
beaucoup ça nous inquiète beaucoup il y
en a bataillé à l'Assemblée nationale
là-dessus pour les petits délits oui
faut savoir qu'au départ il voulait
mettre en place 3400 délits en amende
pour faire faire des rituels ça veut
dire que quand vous avez une amende
forfaitaire forfaitaire délictuelle
c'est dur à dire vous ne passez pas
devant un juge donc vous avez pas le
droit à la défense un avocat au
contradictoire il n'y a pas
d'individualisation de la peine et en
plus le gouvernement en commission des
lois Emmanuel
monsieur Darmanin et le groupe
Renaissance ont ajouté des AFD si vous
avez des lycéens majeurs qui
occupent leur lycée par exemple ou si
vous avez des entraves à la circulation
c'est à dire l'occupation de rond-point
ça veut dire que à quelques semaines de
la grande bataille sur les retraites ou
le gouvernement s'est pertinemment qui
va y avoir une mobilisation d'ampleur
qu'on se projeter régressif de retraite
à 65 ans il crée des amendes forfaitaire
délictuelles de 500 à 1600 euros pour
criminaliser finalement les lycéens qui
pourraient occuper leur lycée en guise
de protestation ou bien des écologistes
qui
occupent des des voies contre l'inaction
climatiques qui ont la vue récemment ça
serait aussi des amants de santé tel
forfaitaire délictuelles qu'aurait pu se
prendre les gilets jaunes donc à
l'approche de la grande bataille sur les
retraites on trouve ça vraiment une
dérive autoritaire extrêmement
problématique pour nos droits nos
libertés fondamentales alors
bibliothèque fait d'accord d'un fait
l'objet d'un accord entre la majorité
présidentielle et la droite que ce soit
chez les députés ou chez les Sénateurs
c'est une alliance logique selon vous
mais c'est un texte de droite donc
forcément quand vous avez un texte de
droite qui n'alliance de droite autour
d'un texte de droite et une surenchère
de droite sécuritaire sur un texte de
droite c'était l'as un schéma assez
classique mais attention votre démagogie
réactionnaire pour de la démagogie
réactionnaire de la droite ne résoudra
rien ne résoudra rien parce que c'est
pas en augmentant les peines que nous
avons une réduction des délits et il y a
aucune étude aucun bilan aucune analyse
qui n'est produite par le gouvernement
lorsqu'il vient aggraver ses dispositifs
allez direction le Sénat où on poursuit
le marathon budgétaire trois textes
étaient discutés cette semaine dans
l'hémicycle le budget de la Sécurité
sociale la rallonge budgétaire face à la
hausse des prix et puis le budget de
l'État 2023 le projet de loi de finance
alors quelle est la position de la
majorité de droite sur ces textes
Jonathan du priez
c'est au tour des sénateurs d'examiner
le budget 2023 qualifié par certains au
Palais du Luxembourg d'irréalistes la
majorité sénatoriale de droite et du
centre projette d'amander en profondeur
le texte afin notamment de contenir les
déficits le rapporteur général du budget
Jean-François Husson déplore
l'incapacité du gouvernement à le faire
depuis la période covid comme vous le
savez les conditions de financement de
la France ne sont plus les mêmes que par
le passé je dirais le temps de l'argent
facile et gratuit et bien fini et ce
n'est pas faute de vous avoir mis en
garde ici au Sénat sur les risques d'un
endettement trop important et massif
nous voulons tenir nos objectifs de
réduction des déficits et de réduction
de la dette et nous tiendrons les
objectifs qui ont été fixés de baisse de
la dette à partir de 2026 et de retour
chez les 100% de déficit en 2027 plutôt
dans la semaine le Sénat a adopté un
autre texte budgétaire le second projet
de finance rectificative qui contient
entre autres 2,8 milliards d'euros de
mesure contre l'inflation risque tourne
carburant ou encore chèque énergie les
sénateurs n'ont pas entravé le
gouvernement pour ces mesures en faveur
du pouvoir d'achat des Français autre
texte clé adopté au Sénat cette semaine
le budget de la Sécurité sociale les
sénateurs inquiets pour le pronostic du
système de santé ont voté leur version
du texte avec des modifications de
taille comme l'ajout d'une nouvelle taxe
sur les mutuelles mais surtout le report
de l'âge légal à la retraite à 64 ans on
ne peut pas encore une fois faire payer
aux générations futures les errances de
nos générations parce qu'en réalité nous
devons travailler plus dès aujourd'hui
pour ne pas que eux ils travaillent plus
à l'avenir mais le gouvernement est en
train de plancher sur une réforme des
retraites pourquoi lui couper l'herbe
sous le pied avec ses amendements je
pense qu'on est pas très éloigné et on
entendra le ministre et nous verrons
reste à savoir ce que le gouvernement
conservera des modifications
sénatoriales le budget de la Sécurité
sociale revient en début semaine
prochaine à l'Assemblée nationale Daniel
Simonet le Sénat donc voté sa propre
réforme des retraites un recul de l'âge
de départ à 64 ans une mesure retirée
par les députés en vue de la nouvelle
lecture du budget de la Sécurité sociale
à l'Assemblée alors que finalement c'est
le même projet de réforme que celui
d'Emmanuel Macron oui on voit que là il
y a une alliance qui est en train de se
préparer entre et Emmanuel Macron et
Heller et on voit bien que la politique
de ce gouvernement est une politique de
droite est une politique de régression
sociale une politique autoritaire et des
nations climatique mais sur la question
des retraites franchement il faut
absolument que celles et ceux qui qui
nous écoutent comprennent il n'y a
absolument aucune nécessité économique
de retarder l'âge de reporter l'âge de
départ à la retraite à 65 ans le
gouvernement nous explique qu'il faut
absolument faire une économie de 8
milliards d'euros mais par exemple la
mesure sur le projet de loi de finance
de suppression de la CVE c'est à dire
l'impôt sur les entreprises de
production bref a fait une économie du
gouvernement de bien fait perdre des
recettes de 8 milliards donc ils ont
fait un cadeau de 8 milliards au
patronage généralement grandes
entreprises pour finalement faire payer
leur système de retraite leur régression
sociale c'est inacceptable alors ce
vendredi au journal Les Échos Élisabeth
borne annoncent de nouvelles aides dès
janvier 2023 une aide sur le carburant
ciblée pour la mouette sur la moitié des
ménages français et notamment les
travailleurs qui font de longs trajets
sur le principe vous ne pouvez pas être
contre ces nouvelles aides non mais tant
mieux à chaque fois qu'il y a un petit
peu de respiration sur le pouvoir
d'achat tellement la situation les
catastrophique mais tout ça va dans le
mur on sait même pas jusqu'à quand ce
sera et puis je vais vous dire une chose
bloquée le prix de l'essence à 1,40 et
la seule est bonne mesure à prendre
d'urgence parce qu'à chaque fois que
vous faites des ristournes ou que le
gouvernement remède des aides finalement
c'est un interdit absolument pas
finalement les prix de l'essence de
continue à augmenter les prix de
l'énergie de continuer à augmenter donc
on a d'une part ceux qui vont se faire
des supers produits et le gouvernement
sur notre argent public sur nos impôts
il prend dans notre poche puis redonne
dans l'autre mais pendant ce temps les
autres se gaz toujours sur notre dos
justement sur les super profits le
gouvernement a finalement accepté l'idée
d'une contribution notamment des
producteurs d'énergie sur leur bénéfice
et puis ce vendredi le patron de Total
annoncé qu'il allait son entreprise en
tout cas les payer l'impôt sur les
sociétés puisque c'est raffinerie font
des profits en France tout cela va dans
le bon sens non mais vous rendez compte
quand même
on a une entreprise totale qui dégage
milliard de bénéfices qui ne payent pas
d'impôts et au lieu d'appliquer
clairement
une taxation de ces super profit sans
tortiller sans hésiter on l'annonce
quand même depuis longtemps c'est des
choses et là on voit qu'en fait ça va
être au rabais ça serait une petite
contribution puis on attend le bon
vouloir le patron total non un moment
donné il faut redistribuer les richesses
c'est là question centrale c'est la
question centrale qui va être qui va
provoquer les mobilisation sociale
notamment déclenchée par la question des
retraites mais c'est la vraie question
qui nous est posée en plus de celle de
de l'inaction climatique dernière petite
question très rapide l'État veut freiner
la hausse des dépenses des collectivités
locales quand on voit la gestion des
finances de certaines collectivités
comme Paris et notamment Wanne Hidalgo a
décidé une hausse faramineuse de la taxe
foncière pour renflouer les caisses
qu'est-ce que vous répondez vous savez
moi je suis né d'opposition au niveau de
la ville de Paris et pour autant sur
l'augmentation de la taxe foncière
l'augmentation elle peut paraître énorme
mais parce que Madame Dalou et la
majorité parisienne n'avait pas eu
recours à l'augmentation de la taxe
frontière depuis des années et on reste
avec un niveau de taxe foncière
inférieure à plein d'autres villes la
question ça va être aussi des critères
sociaux d'exonération si on a des petits
propriétaires
qui l'ont eu passe par héritage de
famille en famille mais qui ont des
faibles et qui ont des faibles revenus
il faut qu'ils en soient exonérés si
c'est bien sûr leurs propriétés où ils
habitent où ils résident par contre les
multiples propriétaires qui sont
responsables de la spéculation
à Paris et bien qui paye plus de taxe
foncières à partir du moment où ce que
j'espère et ça va être la bataille que
la vie de Marie Paris avec les moyens
sur le contrôle de l'encadrement des
loyers pour que ce soit pas au locataire
de payer et bien c'est justice sociale
et on va conclure Daniel Simonet en
regardant l'agenda la semaine prochaine
au Parlement
[Musique]
et au Sénat toute la semaine sera donc
consacrée à l'examen du budget de l'État
pour 2023 le projet de loi de finance et
à l'Assemblée c'est parti pour l'examen
du projet loi ENR énergies renouvelable
qui a été votée par le Sénat ce sera
lundi dès lundi en commission
parlementaire et c'est la fin de cette
émission merci beaucoup Daniel Simonet
d'y avoir participé et merci à tous de
l'avoir suivi ciao ciao
[Musique]